and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review and us
again oh my gosh this is the greatest
movie I've ever seen in my life
do you like uncle Kingston space you do
well that's why our Spears's kid called
ender probably named that because it
sounds like a good title for a book and
she has to stop this neon attack sort of
Delian tech already happened to have to
stop it from happening again but they're
certain that they're going to try it
again sort of they don't really know
what they're up to they just know they
have weapons of mass destruction no it's
too dated so they have all these kids
man their weapons and be the military
why because they're more susceptible to
doing that stuff okay if the world is in
danger I'm not relying a little miss
sunshine to save me speaking of which
she's in this movie although she doesn't
make the cut because well she's Little
Miss Sunshine if there was a
dance contest for child stars though
he'd probably go to Miley Cyrus
surrender is really intimidating because
he's taken under the control of Indiana
Jones oh not cool sexy Nia Jones but
bottom teeth bulldog Indiana Jones your
only hope and you need to save us but
Endor is like but what if I say this the
wrong way for the wrong reason then
you'll officially be an American beat
this but we had to get rid those pecs on
your face so you look more like an
American product oh but I play connect
the dots with those seriously if that
chickenpox Joe Andrews concern because
he has an older brother who's a douche
bag and a younger sister who's a female
Jesus and she wants to be somewhere in
the middle
female douche Jesus but Indian Jones is
like I'm gonna try and sabotage you and
make you looking popular in front of
everybody why would you do that
increasingly unlikable person so I can
have better control over you having
better control over me is making me hate
you I want to disrespect you every
chance that I get hey if it weren't for
me as a celebrity it can work for me in
this role so Endor comes across the two
great girl and she's like I'm gonna show
you how to play this game that's
training us for the future like if I
have you played you
Oh gravity shooting everybody with
incredible physical strength so doing
stuff that in no way will tie into how
we defeat the alien pretty much weak
weak energy surprising everybody with
how smart and talented Hughes he even
opens up this computer game with two
glasses of poison and his giant that
says choose which one you want and
there's like I choose the one in your
eyeball but there is no one in my
eyeball out but and one of the people in
Georgia say oh my god no one has ever
thought to do that in the game
I find that very hard to believe these
are kids were as soon as they see a gun
they're like shoot me shoot me you ain't
think if they put a huge giant in front
of them that they wouldn't think to
attack him
I see giants all the time and I never
back down from that man and this is I'm
sobering up London has a police say in
which case I run very quickly but I only
did that once and it will haunt me to my
grave so they take enter to this
different planet where he comes across
Queequeg and quick way is like are you
sacrifice my life to save humanity but
you're still alive I didn't say I did it
well and all his buddies are flown into
protecting these giant simulations I was
in a simulation once life is a
simulation think about that and so it's
all building up to the great big grey
simulation before he goes and does the
real thing though he goes into the
simulation and fights off all the aliens
with all the grown-ups watching and
their asshole seem particularly tight
for some reason and in the simulation he
blows up the alien planet hurry but it
turns out was no simulation at all it
was the real thing hey wait stop yeah
but ender feels bad cuz he's not sure if
he did for the right reason Hey
okay hurry but in here Jones is like
this is the only way we thought you'd be
able to do it but I thought was just a
game I didn't know was realized that
game cost thousands of people their
lives but also defended us from an alien
attack damn iam a jerk you know what you
just did what you mean argument that
video games kill people now totally
legit now tons of crazy liberals and
conservatives has something to back them
up oh yeah I'm sure that'll really hurt
the video game industry okay good point
but you're so dose but suddenly the
Queen alien gets in contact with enter
telepathically and she lets him know
that she was just a few feet away from
his room the whole time
what do they explain down the book if I
could read I will totally check up on
that but the Queen is like take care of
my baby and be sure to hide him far away
but we're preferably in a very obvious
spot as I was hiding the whole time just
a few feet away from your headquarters
I'll put her under my welcome mat how
about that sounds good so he sneaks the
baby aboard a ship which if I can't get
liquid on an airplane he's supposed to
get an alien life for him on a spaceship
and he flies away to figure out what to
do with a feature of the species oh the
aliens and man hey so oh boy this movie
really makes you think like what would
Lucas hostas clone look like if you just
sprinkled some ink on his face I know I
shouldn't be so harsh on but to his
credit he's gonna have a lot more good
acting jobs than I am until he turns 18
in which case he has to himself up
for some reason
I don't know it's the new child actor
law sake has really added some strange
new rules he says just to meet bum sing
area babies they got alien babies though
come on I want start my own race come on
alien babies come on I'll clone his DNA
with my DNA you know could you tell
gimmick
you